[Music]
moments later started to become clear
someone was trudging through the water
behind us and coming for our boat hello
and welcome to all daint a creepypasta
horror stories cooked to perfection with
a splash of red sauce my name is Susie
and I will be your server this episode
today's story is set at the happiest
place on earth but even the happiest
places have a dark side let's dig right
in
come on Tom let's go let's go hear that
annoying voice rushing me out the door
that's my little brother Shawn today I'd
be responsible for escorting Shawn and
his friend Nick to Disneyland for his
birthday
sure I wasn't looking forward to getting
up early nor was I looking forward to
keeping an eye on two 11 year olds all
day but I have to admit I was kind of
excited to spend the day at Disney it
had been a long time since my parents
had taken me there so I was kind of
looking forward to revisiting the likes
of Space Mountain Haunted Mansion and of
course Pirates of the Caribbean what I
hadn't taken into account was that my
brother had never been to Disney so
although he was excited when we actually
got there and he saw the size of
everything Shawn became a little bit
more timid we had to work our way up to
the more exciting attractions for me
this was a bit of a drag I wasn't
exactly looking forward to riding Peter
Pan or Buzz Lightyear when I told my mom
I would take him to the park for the day
and while I do admit that the Buzz
Lightyear ride is actually pretty fun I
made sure to gradually acclimate him to
the thrill rides as well starting with
the gadget go coaster to Big Thunder and
eventually hitting Matterhorn bobsleds
and even Space Mountain it was getting
close to dusk when I suggested we check
out Pirates of the Caribbean Shawn had
been hesitant about it all day I tried
to explain that it was much tamer than
Space Mountain or any of the other
coasters we had been on that day but he
resisted there was something about being
in a boat and being in the dark that
didn't sit well with him but with a
little arm-twisting and the added
element of him not wanting to look like
a [ __ ] in front of his friend I was
able to get pirates on our agenda that
evening as we queued I could see my
brother starting to get nervous he does
this thing where he runs his hands
through his hair when he's nervous and
right now his hair was a mess
there was something different about this
time though sure he did this during all
the lines for rides he was nervous to go
on but he just had this look in his eye
that was somehow different when we were
standing in line for pirates I told
myself that he'd get over it once he'd
experienced the ride once and tried not
to make a big deal out of it he kept on
asking me questions how many drops are
there do you get wet does it go
pitch-black
will the pirates touch you I just about
couldn't take any more incessant
pestering by the time we'd reached the
front of the line
our boat pulled into the station and we
filled in sticking with the usual
seating arrangement of Nick Shawn than
me but then Shawn jumps out of his seat
and crossed over to the right side of
the station come on I told him this
rides nothing then his friend Nick
jumped out and offered to skip the ride
with him great my 1 bargaining tool was
gone
you can go we'll meet you by that I
considered this for a moment mom would
probably kill me if she knew I'd let
them go by themselves still we'd waited
for so long and this was one of my
favorite rides he was 11 years old now
and they were together what's the worst
that could happen
fine but you stay together and meet me
right by the exit and with that Nick and
Sean disappeared into the dark of the
synthetic bayou
my boat took off I was in the third row
in front of me there were two parents
and their young son in the front row was
occupied by two kids about Shawn's age
and their mom seeing them momentarily
made me regret leaving Nick and Shawn on
their own perhaps they weren't old
enough to look after themselves yet I
made myself wash that thought away with
the soothing sounds of the Swan but as
those sounds faded away I felt a chill
go up my spine he come seeking
adventures and salty old pirate days but
keep a weather eye open sand hold on
tight with both hands if your feets
there be squalls ahead and Davy Jones's
Locker
don't the kid in front of me grabbed
onto his dad's arm for comfort this was
it the first and biggest drop the ride
had to offer I threw my hands into the
air and the kids around me screamed as
we plunge down into the darkness only
something was not right when we splashed
down at the bottom for one it was still
pitch black usually this part of the
ride was led with blue and green colored
lights that accented the inside of the
cavern the other difference was the lack
of music the bottom of the drop should
be accompanied by the song a pirate's
life for me but instead all I could hear
was the crashing of water around me
echoing in every which direction off the
cavernous walls I can no longer see the
kids and parents in front of me as the
area was pitch black but I could hear
one of them crying and the parents
trying to comfort him to be fair that
kid had every right to be scared because
as anyone who's ridden the ride knows
there was a second drop coming but with
no light or sound to tip us off as to
when it would happen it could come at
any moment all we had to go on was the
crashing sounds of the waterfall getting
louder and louder I felt my stomach drop
hard when it had
and I have to say those drops feel much
faster and scarier in the complete dark
but after that we just floated I
honestly could barely tell if we were
going anywhere
I know that we drifted away from the
drop but even as my eyes adjusted to the
dark I still could not see much of
anything I began to wonder if it was
just a show that was broken or if the
entire ride system was done my biggest
fear was getting stuck on the ride and
Shawn and Nick not knowing what to do
wandering off there was some chatter
from the other guests the kids asking
what would happen the parents and myself
trying to figure out what to do there
was no cell reception at one point we
decided to call out no response though I
knew it was a long shot we discussed the
possibility of a power outage and what
would happen if that were the case how
long would we be trapped down here was
it a good idea to go out on foot before
we could come to a decision suddenly the
power seemed to kick back on all at once
and that was when probably the most
terrifying thing happened the voice
chanting dead men tell no tales boomed
over us as a strobe light viciously
overloaded my retinas the shock of these
two events would have been enough to
give someone a heart attack but what I
saw in the light is something that still
chills me to this day we were at the
shipwreck scene if you're not familiar
with the ride there's a portion where a
strobe light occasionally illuminates
the image
Elton gripping the steering wheel of a
destroyed vessel during a heavy
rainstorm the scene is mostly a dark
silhouette in front of the stormy night
sky but when the lightning struck there
was someone standing there staring at us
and I can tell you right now this was no
animatronic I obviously didn't get a
great look at him in that short split
second but he had a big bushy beard it
was hard to tell if he was even dressed
to fit the ride or if he was just some
guy in the dark jacket despite having
only seen him for a fraction of a second
I couldn't get his fiery stare out of my
head almost immediately after this the
lights shut back off in the audio slowed
to his stop it was pretty clear at this
point that they were having power issues
again if you're not familiar with the
rides layout the shipwreck scene is
normally only like a minute past that
second drop but we had already been
floating for at least five minutes at
this point here's the other thing that
bothered me that guy I saw if that was
in fact an employee of the park wouldn't
he be helping us out right now to
evacuate the ride knowing that there
aren't usually any live actors on the
ride it gave me an uneasy feeling about
seeing the guy I wasn't sure if any of
the others and my boat had noticed but I
didn't want to freak out those kids any
more than they already were so I didn't
say anything we sat in near silence for
probably another ten minutes
I tried using my phone light to scope
things out and see where we were I was
almost shaking at the thought of seeing
that guy again in the dark I surveyed
around great so we'd only moved
backwards from where we were before
after turning my phone right back off
we sat for a short while longer and as
we waited I started to notice a
splashing that seemed to be coming from
behind us
moments later it started to become clear
someone was trudging through the water
behind us and coming for our boat I
didn't want to alarm the other riders so
at first I just ignored it hoping that
it was in my head or something and that
it would just go away but it became
quite obvious to everyone involved that
there was a person walking directly
towards our boat I looked back and my
eyes were again met with an
uncomfortably bright light this time a
flashlight that was pointed up directly
in my face my heart was beating out of
my chest who was this guy was it the guy
I'd seen earlier my questions were soon
answered by a voice that called out to
us hey guys my name is captain Carter
sorry about the inconvenience
we're actually experiencing a park-wide
power outage right now so I'm gonna ask
that you and your entire crew stay
seated well I got just shipped back to
safety the voice was coming from a
costume cast member wearing thigh-high
rubber boots and just walking through
the middle of the ride track she
actually ended up just pushing our boat
all the way across the ride to the
market scene where several other ride
boats were lined up and many other cast
members with flashlights were assisting
them to a hidden stairway leading out of
the ride I have to admit they had a
pretty efficient system for getting
people out in the event of an emergency
two men in uniform were helping hoist
guests out of the boat and sending them
down to the emergency exit while I
waited for my turn I had one question
weighing heavy on my mind excuse me
captain Carter was it yes I have a
question when the power came back on
earlier for just a couple seconds I
started
I stand in there just looking at us oh
that must have been one of the
animatronics coming back on sometimes it
takes a few minutes after a shutdown
are there any animatronics over in that
area though like by the shipwright I'm
not sure I don't think so but I'd have
to check on that I would later take to
youtube to confirm what I saw was not an
animatronic the uniform guys then helped
me out of the boat I thought it must be
one of the few Disney guests to ever get
to walk the area of the ride scene on
foot I was the last guest to evacuate
the ride and I was advised to use my
phone light and follow along the
cobblestone until I reached a staircase
which I was to use to exit I made it to
the stairs when I felt that same chill
go up my spine just as I had before the
power had gone out I looked all around
me on my left was the backside of the
fake walls that made up the rides
backdrop it seemed to be used as a
little storage area the other side was a
little pathway for the staff members
blocked by a ladder so I continued ahead
up towards another staircase but before
I exited the right area before I got
back to my brother and his friend before
I walked them back to the car not
letting them out of my sight for even
the slightest a moment before I left
that right area I heard the faintest
sound emanating in the distance behind
me
[Music]
thanks for listening to all Danes a
creepypasta your total today comes out
to 117 dollars but if you like this
video right now I'll waive that fee and
give you everything you just listen to
absolutely free I'd like to give a huge
thank you to my collaborators on this
video
Robert Austin for composing the original
music elixir Marc bot and don't turn
around for contributing their narrations
and Mayo yasaku Matta for performing
this and theme you can find the links to
their channels in the credits section at
the bottom of the description let me
know in the comments what other rides I
should write a scary story about but
before you exit this ride please stop by
our gift shop where you can find the new
C's world like pillows with 17 different
color options remember to subscribe to
see these ones for new Horrors every
week ring that death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survived
[Music]